joining me here on the rich eisen show
on the mercedes-benz van phone line is
one of our favorites uh fresh off of the
practice field for the buffalo bills
getting set for a monday night football
contest that i will be doing the pregame
and halftime show of on westwood one
sports emanuel sanders how are you
emanuel
i'm good how you doing are you aware
that i've been sitting here tap dancing
on the air while you're doing extra
passes and extra catching on the
practice field what's going on emmanuel
hey man trying to get better you know we
got a big game coming up well your
professionalism's getting in the way of
my show emanuel what's going on
how dare you
hey man i gotta hey i got two kids to
feed
i've got three well at any rate i'm
thrilled that i'm i'm thrilled that
you're here uh what is your sense of
things entering december in buffalo for
this team i mean you've been on
championship teams you know what they
look like you know what they feel like
you know we got to do right now in afc
nobody's taking over and the playoff
picture is looking
like you know who knows who can get in
and so i mean we understand the sense of
urgency around here that you know we got
we got we got to win some games and it
starts on monday night you know in terms
of if we want to win the afc
it goes to you know new england right
now they're the top seed of the afce so
uh you know we know we got to handle
business and we're up for the challenge
and you also know what it's like to take
on a belichick defense obviously from
your first few years in the league
significantly in all those games where
the afc writ large the the conference
came down to a lot of those new england
pittsburgh games that you were in what
do you think is coming your way on
monday night
i mean i mean
uh it's crazy look at the patriots you
know last year after time left like okay
all right they got that they're in a
rebuilding year and then you see
belichick make all these moves in the
offices he's like oh okay can he can't
he really put it together and then they
draft like uh you know mac jones and now
all of a sudden it seems like you know
the patriots are back you know and
uh when i when i mean back it seems like
championship caliber tight type team and
you know they're they're they're on a
win streak right now they're hot they're
coming in
they're believing they can win and so
you know obviously we know we know
exactly what the patriots way is we know
that you know they have a winning
culture over there but at the same time
uh you know it's it's a fight for the
afce
uh you know and so well like i said
we're up for the challenge what's your
favorite josh allen story what do you
have for me
on that one josh oh man i got way too
many stories this guy every day i come
into work you know he's like that's
like today like hey what's up grandpa
how you doing grandpa
grandpa yeah you know oh well i found
out i was the oldest receiver in the nfl
and
you know a lot of people look at it like
uh it's a bad thing i look at it like
it's a good thing hey man i i survived
everybody you know like i'm i'm i'm the
only other league in terms of receivers
right now and it feels good because you
know uh yesterday um you know at
practice i clocked 20 20 miles an hour i
was the third fastest on that day
and uh you know to be the oldest you see
him at least still doing that man it
felt good you know and so uh what's
really gonna feel good is go out and
make some plays and really get a win on
monday and um you know be able to you
know keep rolling and keep winning and
hopefully you know
win it all at some point so you said
grandpa got ticketed for speeding is
that what you're telling me that story
emmanuel
would you tell me
in the 15 mile an hour zone
so you know you know on that on the
field there is no speed limit on the
football field you know what i mean they
encourage grandpa to go faster
wow okay so josh allen's having fun like
that um but it does appear that you do
have a connection
with him right now
how does that develop how did you
develop that with with him obviously
over the last three months i think it's
just i think it's just two competitors
but at the same time like
uh we kind of get each other too uh josh
is one of those guys man like
he understands that football is a game
he and he plays the game of football
not only from you know a mental
standpoint of from a professionalism
standpoint he has all that but also just
from a kid's standpoint of how he plays
the game and having fun because it is a
game of play and he he reminds me that
every day because sometimes you know and
you know my 12 year career like i get so
caught up in just the pro the the job
part of it i forget that you know it's
it's a blessing to play a game uh you
know football is a game but they pass a
lot of money sometimes you get lost in
it you know coming into work and seeing
this do it every day like i mean his
wittiness the way he wants to joke
around but also be serious at the same
time
it just makes it just makes work so much
fun and you know i'm having the time of
my life about it how good is diggs
emmanuel how could how good is this
exception with the exception of the
weather right now today it was cold
outside called today well i emanuel i
hate to tell you you're living in
western new york man i mean this just
it's just in it's gonna get colder it's
going to get good exactly
that's what everyone's telling me yeah i
know so how good has diggs been you got
a front row seat now seeing him up close
and perfect oh man man he's good uh man
today at practice i was just watching
like i said it was cold outside and this
guy's coming bursting off the ball
he's running into the huddle he's
dancing he's having fun and
one of the hardest working guys i've
been around it's a reason why he's had
so much success
uh just from a competitive standpoint
being on the sideline on
on game day with this guy like i tell
him like digs he's already you know he's
already you know digs in terms of that
practice but on the on game day he turns
into like a whole nother like monster
he's just
so competitive and so like
locked in and just so just screaming i i
tell people all the time like every game
digs is gonna lose his voice because
he's screaming he's hollering getting
the guys going he's bringing so much
energy to the game
um you know
out of everybody i'm playing with like
he's the most energetic player i think
i've i've ever played with and
passionate player that i've ever played
with in terms of showing it and in his
emotions and the way he go about his
business yeah that that i i don't even
call it a route that he ran on
thanksgiving night um what was that like
in the film session looking at that one
again on the goal line that he's going
to touchdown
and it's crazy because you know when i
was watching film he had ran
uh
a similar
uh like a slant route
um on marshawn probably like 15 plays
prior to that but he won on the slant
and so and the release that he took
he took this exact same release on that
return route but except instead of
slanting in he slandered him and then
broken back out that just goes to show
what type of route running uh
capabilities you have in terms of how
he's setting up guys in the game knowing
that at some point it's gonna be you
know another move off that same route
off that same release so uh he's one of
the best in the game like i said he was
all pro last year
um you know one of the best in the game
you know i've been fortunate enough to
play with a lot of good receivers
antonio brown to various times michael
thomas not him just seeing how these
guys go about their business that's the
reason why he has so much success well
you've been in it for now your 12th
season here super bowl 50 champion
emmanuel sanders here on the rich eisen
show couple minutes left with the
buffalo bill and so you know you know
again speaking of bill that's belichick
on the other sideline and that defense
is coming and they've been balling out
and so much conversation that it feels
like 2001 for them all over again you
know what i'm referring to uh or the
fact is again that they've got their
championship feeling back and again you
were part of those steelers teams when
you first
started playing to see all of that you
know you got to hold turf right you got
to hold your turf on this this this
monday nighter it's that crucial because
otherwise you got to go there next time
and you can still win there obviously
but that the assignments get tougher do
you have a sense that this is all of
that
on monday night like that it's like it's
like that one uh
thing that's going viral in terms of
tick tock when they say i understood
this the assignment you know we we
definitely understand the assignment and
they understand that assignment and it's
a five-star match-up uh it's a reason
why it's on primetime football monday
night football the whole world is gonna
be watching and what a beautiful thing
for the nfl uh buffalo bills josh allen
versus uh the new england pages the hot
team who nobody really um you know
thought you know would be as high as
they were especially with a ricky
quarterback at least from my perspective
and they got a defense that's that's
that's that's lights out they got a
young quarter young hot rookie
quarterback and they got bill belichick
one of the greatest if not the greatest
you know nfl coaches of all time so
what a beautiful night in buffalo and
what a what a big opportunity for us you
know to capitalize on the moment and i
hope we do and how about you too you
know what i mean like as you mentioned
uh grandpa's how you're being referred
to you're 12 for you you've come back
from injuries multiple times i mean this
is it you're in a game it's significant
as any other in the nfl in this 2021
season it's just got to feel great for
you i feel great for you oh oh it feels
amazing uh and you know my son
um you know i tell him all the time i
said it's crazy to be on on a
championship caliber team you know and
at year 12 you know and starting you
know uh that's the best part about it
right it's not like i'm on some you know
on six team just trying to maintain a
league league
i'm i'm still producing and still
relevant and it feels good like you know
these are the things that you know most
people wouldn't say but if it does feel
good and and that's true like it feels
good to be in the league in year 12
still competing for for championships
and so it's definitely a blessing and
and you know i'm trying to take full
advantage of it yeah and uh the guy you
won super bowl 50 with is going to be
talking about you on that manning cast
too he'll be out there he's part of the
paparazzi emmanuel yeah that's my guy
you know so that'll be part of it hey
have a great have a great game thanks
for hopping off of the practice field
and hopping on here i i greatly
appreciate it always enjoy our chats and
and um you know i think the world so
thanks again appreciate it i appreciate
you rich right back at you right back at
you it's emmanuel sanders
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here